well there's an awful lot of evidence
that congresswoman Ilhan Omar married
her own brother
illegally as a kind of immigration fraud
but that's not the only drama in her
personal life now Amara has filed from
for divorce from her next husband
this comes after allegations of an
affair with the political consultant
chief breaking news correspond trace
Gallagher has more on the story hey
trace hey Tucker she filed for divorce
on Friday her 37th birthday and court
documents obtained by our corporate
cousin New York Post says she is seeking
joint custody of their children
appropriate child support and to split
the marital assets pretty basic stuff
court papers also say representative
Omar says the marriage had a quote
irretrievable breakdown unclear if that
breakdown involved a DC consultant named
Tim my net whom she was allegedly having
an affair but just a few weeks ago my
net filed court papers denying the
affair which is curious considering his
estranged wife dr. Beth my net says her
husband fully admitted it and mrs. myNet
was furious saying her husband put their
thirteen-year-old son in danger by
publicly introducing the boy to Omar who
quote at the time had garnered a
plethora of media attention along with
death threats one rising to the level of
arresting the known would-be assassin
that same week that my net says the
affair began while her husband was
working for Elon Omar's campaign and now
conservative watchdog groups have filed
complaints with the Federal Election
Commission because Omar's campaign
reportedly paid Tim my net and his firm
two hundred thirty thousand dollars for
things like fundraising travel expenses
question now is whether those funds were
used to pursue the affair ilan omar omar
married
Achmed Hirsi in a religious ceremony
back in 2002 they separated in 2008 then
legally married last year Omar as you
said also accused of marrying her
biological brother so he could obtain
American citizenship